the editor's note says this quote lacia
clarendon who identifies as transgender
and non-binary
uses he him she her and they them
pronouns interchangeably
what you too are now supposed to be
drafted into this movement
to normalized delusion yesterday i was
browsing this world of sports and i came
across an article
that was so astonishing in its stupidity
and confusion that it forcibly struck me
i mean it really was
the single worst piece of writing i have
ever seen and the reason it was the
single worst piece of writing
i've ever seen is because it is utterly
incoherent i want to read it to you
it's about a person named lucia
clarendon the wnba's first
openly non-binary and transgender player
okay it's by a person named katie barnes
okay
here is the peas i'm gonna read the
first three paragraphs
and you will immediately not understand
anything okay
this is a thing that a human wrote lacia
clarendon
wrapped their hand around the back of a
fussy newborn looking up at them
in the maternity recovery room at a bay
area hospital a nurse had just shown
lacia how to cradle the baby in a
football hold
unless she arrested the soft skin of the
baby's back against her
own left forearm and held the baby's
head in her hand
okay so at the beginning you're like
okay so we're talking about non-binary
person who wants to be called them
within the same paragraph this person is
now being called her
but wait bbc they them because the baby
doesn't have a gender either okay we're
now working in this
bizarre universe in which a baby comes
out we know whether it's a boy or a girl
but we pretend we don't know whether
it's a boy or a girl because literally
you can change your gender up to the day
you die
and then after you die and after your
body decays and all that's left is your
bone structure scientists a thousand
years from now
can also know whether you're a boy or a
girl in any case
they them baby c they them gurgled and
squirmed at lacia's touch
lacia accepted shampoo from the nurse
silently wondering if it would be
appropriate
for black hair with her right hand she
gently rubbed her fingers through the
silky curls of baby c's full head of
hair
so so far it's a woman right a woman who
identifies as they them that's what you
can
get from the first couple paragraphs
here's where things take a sideways turn
it was december 21st 2020 babysie's
birthday and first wash day
lacia's wife jessica she her had just
given birth to baby c by cesarean
section after a 29-hour labor
after carrying the baby for just over 41
weeks as jessica recovered lesia found
himself alone with his first child
i know what you're thinking what
he never expected to have these first
moments alone with baby c lacia and
jessica had planned for a vaginal birth
and four of these moments
to be shared exhausted and weak jessica
joined leicester and babysit in the
recovery room 30 minutes later
lacia held the baby up to jessica's
chest to assist with babysit's first
meal
as jessica drifted off leshia placed
babysitte back in the hospital bassinet
he removed his shirt and sat down lacia
picked the baby back up cradling baby c
against their chest
um so in the first several paragraphs of
this piece
we now learn that lacia clarendon is
referred to as
wait for it they them
her she he
and him now this makes a mockery of
language
right you have no id you you now have
less information about lacia clarendon
than you did at the beginning of the
piece
you don't know anything about lacia
clarendon if you just read this piece if
you're an alien from outer space or a
normal english speaker
either of the two and you read this
piece you would not know whether lacia
clarendon is a boy
or a girl or anything else it makes no
sense
it's deliberate confusion it's
deliberate confusion
and if you mention that it's deliberate
confusion then you are called a bigot
if you point out that this is absolutely
nonsensical
that the ex the terms he and she
and they have quite specific meanings in
english he refers to males
she refers to females and they generally
first refers
to the plural unless it is a they at the
end of a sentence and it is referring
back to a she or he antecedent
typically but here you have
all of these terms being used for one
person the only purpose here
is to convey less information with
language it is to isolate you more
it's to make you feel more confused for
the sexual revolutionary left confusion
is the point boys and girls they're not
supposed to mean anything
they're all social constructs unless
sexual orientation is invoked in which
case it's not a social construct it's
biological
reality but also you can shape your
sexual orientation and choose it over
time
it can be bisexual or pansexual or gay
or lesbian
or straight at any time you can identify
as any of those things
but they are both biologically immutable
and also social constructions
according to the radical left and we
have now entered the world of michel
foucault in which
language is just power the arbitrary
shifts in language
are designed to promote power just as in
an authoritarian governmental system
arbitrary shifts of the rules that
you're supposed to know and you get
punished if you find yourself in breach
of those rules they are designed to
simply
re-enshrine and reinforce the power of
the system over you
radical shifts in language where words
suddenly don't mean what they meant five
seconds ago
and where if you use the word in its
traditional sense you have now crossed
some invisible line you become a bigot
this is a way for the social left to
rule your life it is a way for the
social left
to out you to treat you as a bigot i
have a new book coming out
called the authoritarian moment and one
of the things that i point out in the
authoritarian moment
is that this power game has now
infiltrated
virtually every institution of our
society to even point this out puts you
at risk of censorship from
the big tech companies even point this
out makes you
a person who shouldn't be welcomed into
play conversation
we now identify each other as members of
the ruling class and there is a ruling
class in the united states the way that
you are identified as a member of the
ruling class the people who deserve to
rule is you put pronouns in your profile
if you've got pronouns in your twitter
profile is not an indicator that there
was any confusion about who you were we
all know who you were because we have
eyes and we have ears and we have
minds right we can identify people based
on objective characteristics
the whole purpose of putting a pronoun
in your profile is not even to
demonstrate solidarity because you've
demonstrated nothing
right we don't really know anything
about your politics simply based on what
pronouns apply to you
all it is a way of signaling that you
speak the vocabulary that you speak woke
it's a socially authoritarian method of
ostracizing people
who think in terms of traditional
objective metrics
now how stupid is this particular espn
story i use this as an example because
this is the cover story espn magazine by
the way okay
so the reason i use this is because not
only is this supremely confusing and
designed to be confusing
there's an editor's note attached the
editor's note says this quote
lacia clarendon who identifies as
transgender and non-binary
again if you are non-binary meaning you
don't
actually have a gender how are you
transgender
are you a woman who became a man are you
a woman who became nothing
are you a woman who became a genderless
widget like what exactly are you
the terms transgender and transgender
suggests that you change your gender
from one to the other typically
non-binary means you don't identify as
any gender
so these two terms should be somewhat
mutually exclusive they're not right
leshia clarendon who identifies as
transgender and non-binary uses
he him she her and they them pronouns
interchangeably
we do so throughout this piece we also
introduce the preferred pronouns for
others who appear in this story and for
whom
pronouns are used okay so instead of the
editors
doing what editors typically do which is
make sure that language
conveys information this is what editors
and writers are designed to do
right there's a post-modern discourse in
literature in which language is not
supposed to convey information
it is instead supposed to enshrine
certain moods it's supposed to generate
certain feelings but
typically the purpose of language is to
convey information
this is true in the animal kingdom as
well whether it's clicks and chirps from
animals or whether it is the human voice
the goal is generally to convey more
information
except now now the goal is to convey
less information because the true
idea is to elicit from you whether you
object to this
and thus can be ostracized safely from
the membership in the new ruling class
and this is nothing new and there's an
article we talked about
on the show way back in april in the new
york times called a guide to neo
pronouns so you are confused by all of
this well let the new york times
guide you through all of this you will
be more confused by the end
than you were at the beginning according
to the new york times
non-binary pronouns have become
widespread a 2019 pew research study
found already that one in five americans
knew someone who uses non-binary
pronouns
and then there are neo pronouns a
neopronoun can be a word created to
serve as pronoun without expressing
gender like g
and jur a neopronoun can also be
a so-called noun self pronoun in which a
pre-existing
word is drafted into use as a pronoun
noun self pronouns can refer to animals
so your pronoun can be bun bun self and
kitten
kitten self others refer to fantasy
characters vamp
vamp self prin says princess self
they fair fair self or even just common
slang like
in it in its in itself
so is this for real says the new york
times yes and around any leading edge
behavior online trolling hijinks and bad
faith collide and distinctly for those
unfamiliar with the culture surrounding
the
pronouns right now it's likely
impossible to distinguish between what's
playful what's deeply meaningful and
what's people being mean
many neo-pronoun users are dead serious
and are also part of online communities
that are quick to react swiftly
to offenses a popular twitch streamer
who goes by andyvmg recently apologized
after tweet jokingly tweeting that her
pronouns were bad af
which led many neo-pronoun users to
accuse her of transphobic invalidation
of their identities
and if emg wrote on twitter it wasn't
meant to mock people who use neopronouns
however i've since educated myself on
the matter and spoken to people who use
neopronouns and i see
why what i said was hurtful
okay now again the idea here that these
neopronouns
kitten kits himself express just the
same amount of information
as a person saying that the person a
biological woman is both he
and she and them precisely nothing
the only thing that it expresses is a
person who
is either unable or unwilling to
identify with reality
that's all but the whole point is that
you too are now supposed to be drafted
into this movement
to normalize delusion you're supposed to
be drafted into this movement
to normalize delusion and this this
notion
that personal identity that how i
identify must be reflected by the
society at large and if you refuse
to go along with my moral vision of
society if you
refuse to clap and cheer along you have
denied me
my identity you have undermined me as a
human being
and corporations because so many
corporations are in the business of
catering
to clientele right this is what
corporations do corporations are going
to sell you what you want to buy
well right now what people want to buy
is a vision of themselves and that
vision of themselves can be anything
and so corporations are simply going to
celebrate whatever
you believe you are in order to make
money right so this has led people on
the right to say capitalism is the
problem
okay capitalism is not the problem
capitalism is just not designed
to be the moral imprimatur okay
capitalism is the greatest system
for the distribution and increase in
wealth in human history
without a doubt but capitalism is not
inherently tied
the system itself is not inherently tied
to anything beyond provision of services
and products to people who want them
and so if you are a business and you are
seeking to cater to people and those
people have
immoral wants capitalism will serve
those wants the same way that would
serve
somebody who has a moral want in other
words
the lack that we are seeing in american
society right now is not the result of
economics
the lack that we are seeing in american
society right now is a result
of lack of a moral basis a moral
foundational grounding in reality
the reality that we are embodied human
beings we are not just a free-floating
spirit
inside a meatball we are actually an
embodied
thing which means that our biology and
our soul are connected
and that means that we cannot ignore our
biology or treat our biology as though
it were our enemy
but that's precisely what the left seeks
to do the left not only seeks to
treat our biology as an enemy the left
seeks to treat you as an enemy
if you even notice the fact that
objective facts which allow us to have
conversations with one another by the
way
that if objective facts exist and you
acknowledge the existence of these
objective facts
you are now engaged in an act of bigotry
right because i'm denying your identity
subjectivism now rules of the day
and anybody who insists on objective
uses of language
that we can share because there has to
be a term that means something in order
for us to both use it and understand one
another if you insist on that you're now
engaged in an act of bigotry
all of this is a power game all of this
is a power game
the the confusion the meaninglessness
that
is the point because if you can make
everybody confused and then if you can
use that confusion
in order to instill in everybody else
the idea that if you refuse to acquiesce
to the confusion
this makes you the bad guy well then you
are just as arbitrary
in your use of power as most
authoritarians are and we have a set of
cultural authoritarians who are who are
joining us in the guise of tolerance and
acceptance which is not what this is
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang